I invested five hundred dollars and got
ten thousand dollars back wow dude you
seem pretty upset after landing such a
sweet deal well the thing is this guy is
no investor in fact he's a hostage some
bad people forced him to record this
video which is actually just a promotion
for a scam and this isn't the only guy
caught in this trap get your money quick
you get it fast the victims record
videos of themselves in the hopes that
hackers will return their stolen money
or logging credentials so how do people
get themselves into this mess it's
pretty simple they simply do what their
friends are already doing who've also
been hacked we're used to trusting what
our friends say especially if they're
reaching out to us personally we see
their familiar face hear their voice and
don't suspect them to be in a hostage
situation to protect yourself use
two-factor authentication and never
reuse your usernames and passwords and
stay on top of the latest fishing
methods too for that we'd recommend
subscribing to our Channel